it before the official start of the ama
but we've already got questions and
people
watching so may as well begin
i've got myself set up with uh i'll be
drinking some of my non-alcoholic
ales that we've found hopefully my wife
and i will get to reviews of views of
those
in the coming months or so
i do want to
address questions right away i do want
to say a few sort of ground rules nobody
needs to ask the same question
more than once because it's in the
stream
doing so just clutters it up i've
answered questions about
peterson zizek all these sort of pop
philosophy figures many many times so i
don't have an awful lot new to say about
them
we do have some good questions over here
i will also say that i'm going to try to
answer one question from a given person
and then move on to somebody else so if
you write a whole bunch of questions
don't expect them all to get answered
because you know this is sharing space
already we got 22 people on here there
may be as many as 100 or 150.
all right so ron james has a funny thing
that he's saying here
in a response to what's up early people
nothing much just waiting for juicy
questions and even juicier answers
from dr sadler is the word salty for
those kinds of answers
and it's interesting because i was
having a conversation with my my wife um
the other day
and she said you know most of the time
when you're talking
with um you know clients and
reading groups and stuff like that you
seem like you're really having a great
time
it kind of goes back and forth with amas
and political theory discussions you
know you sound like you're you're uh
irritated with some of the stuff and and
you know i thought about that a bit and
i was like well you know sometimes i
actually am you know when people ask me
the same question that i get asked month
after month um that's kind of you know
bad form but for the most part um i
actually enjoy these quite a lot so
but i will get salty if people ask there
are dumb questions i'll put it to you
that way
all right uh galen i'm not going to
satisfy entirely can you give one or two
examples of greek and roman philosophers
who would be good for beginner
intermediate
and
uh advanced students of greek and latin
to try to original
probably not because i'm not a
um classics guy and i don't i don't
teach people how to read green latin i
can tell you what i did
and that might be helpful for you
although
there are so many other authors out
there who like i haven't read and or if
i've read them i haven't read them in
the original
let's take latin
um
somebody who's really
quite easy to read but is not somebody
in classics would be thomas aquinas
right
the
language of the summa and also his
commentaries and a lot of the minor
works is deliberately
easy i won't say dumb down but it's
pretty easy
latin to read and that's that's where i
ended up going back after i
mistakenly tried to jump into advanced
level stuff namely cicero
um
you know other latin stuff
good question you know um
i guess i would say that seneca's latin
is kind of intermediate there's a lot of
rhetorical structure there but
you know it's it's pretty readable um
and
you know and some of canterbury somebody
who i read a lot that would work
um i would say
at the advanced level augustine
uh cicero you know people like that i
mean there's also loctancias who i
haven't actually read in the latin yet
but apparently his latin is supposed to
be really good and he might be between
intermediate and
and advanced now in the greek i mean i'm
reading greek stuff basically
uh either out of curiosity or as a
research tool
aristotle's definitely easier to read
than plato and his his writing is not
koine but it's kind of in between attic
greek and coin a i can tell you that
when i took the greek sequence um
they had us starting out for our early
like
take the training wheels off we're going
to actually read a book
we read some speeches by lysius
and then we read lucian's true history
and lucian you know lucian can be tricky
but he's he's he's not bad
and we read plato's um credo which is a
pretty straightforward work
um
and then you just kind of progress you
know i i didn't do these things the way
that many other people do
i would say
all right um
massacre how should i read use freud for
philosophy is he of any value today
really psychological late sociocultural
freud is he more useful for ethics
epistemology hermeneutics useful
secondary lit i'm not going to go into
usual secondary layer that's a lot
question already there
um you should read freud as if people at
either extreme of talking about freud
so the people who are like freud has
been totally debunked man he's no good
[ __ ] all right people who are like
freud has got the answers for everything
they're full of [ __ ] i've always been
full of [ __ ] right
um
in the middle you're going to find
people who are like well he's got some
useful insights he's got some
limitations as well
to
his approach there's a lot of
assumptions built in which maybe we want
to question you can also look at some of
the people that are working off of freud
or are connected to them and i'm going
to bring up two in particular
one is lou andreas salome one of the
early students of freud who also like
was you know at the time that she begins
her correspondence with him she's also
taking stuff with oddler who by that
time is one of the enemies right
um
and she's got some interesting you know
discourse with him she
went on this
she's also you know she's a woman uh
she's not sort of the typical woman uh
but she she is bringing some
perspectives to freud and freudianism
seeing some of the blind spots the other
person is kind of interesting is jacques
lacan you know laka views his works as a
return to the original true insights of
freud that have been already papered
over
just decades after freud has given them
by the freudian establishment and so
when you're going through lacan's works
you're seeing somebody who's like a
reformer in a certain way right
reformers and going back
to
the original and saying that we need to
do that um i teach freud in like my
philosophy of human nature class because
he does have you know a viewpoint on
human nature and and i i have my
students uh read some of the stuff about
the you know tripartite psychology
um and and some of the stuff the later
stuff that you're talking about where
it's more sociocultural
uh you know you can just like with
anybody else you want to read it with
some attention to when it's coming out
and what he's responding to
and you also want to you know take what
he has to say with the proverbial grain
of salt right
i will say this i was just working with
a client last week and we were looking
at parts of james's the varieties of
religious experience
there in the chapter on conversion
continued james actually brings up freud
and a whole bunch of other people who he
says are working doing basically the
same thing you know noticing that we
have what freud calls subconscious or
unconscious other people are calling
other things james calls subliminal
consciousness so you know a lot of
freud's ideas are not like radically
out of the blue or anything like that so
that's that's worth keeping in mind
all right mark has is asking uh how's it
going i hope i'm feeling better i was i
was sick uh for a week and a half real
fatigued
kind of a sinus headache and stuff like
that
i am feeling better i'm not feeling
better yet to go to the gym but i'm
feeling a good bet good bit better i
mentioned a few amas ago that my
favorite movie is the duelists i watched
it recently
great film interesting exploration of
thumbos yeah so
that is good insight um if you don't if
you're not familiar with this film that
we're referencing it is a
early ridley scott film
just gorgeous that's one of the reasons
why i love it so much because
the way it's filmed the scenery the
whatever you call the backdrops that
they're in
uh staging i guess
uh the music score is it really places
you in there and it's just it's
beautiful and it's two main characters
um
harvey keitel is a kind of a prick
officer very uh full of himself uh
causing trouble getting in trouble in
the napoleonic wars on the french side
and is it uh it's peter carradine is i
think
is or is it keith um one of the one of
the carradines is the
the officer who is told to go and arrest
harvey keitel and it leads to the first
duel between the two of them and then
it's inconclusive and they begin
dueling every time they meet and now
harvey caitel wants to duel
and
the the other main character the
caridian character is trying to avoid as
much as possible but he's actually the
better dualist and
you know
in a way you could say that we want to
think of it in terms of like control
over
this this active passionate
aggressive part of ourselves that is
involved in attacks defense social
status harvey keitel is driven by
thumbos and whenever you're driven by
just the most you screw up a lot
and the other guy has got thumos in in
control but he has to have it because
otherwise he's going to get killed by
harvey keitel's character right
so yeah you know that would be a good
film to watch and actually maybe have
like a
a discussion group about you know i kind
of like that idea
all right let's see
elijah asks how do you put blondel into
dialogue with hegel and mcintyre so
that's a good question so blondel here
is maurice blondell not eric blondell
the
nietzsche
author who is big when i was in graduate
school
maurice blondell is a very important
19th century 20th century
french catholic philosopher
as a matter of fact i have the book
actually he has
i've been in front
in things uh the bulk of my first book
of translations is actually bits and
pieces of blondel's stuff
and i wrote my dissertation on maurice
blume
blondel is often called the catholic
kegel or the french angle because
they're both taking dialectical
systematic approaches to things
um blondel red hegel what we know that
he read is primarily the science of
logic the phenomenology was not big
at the time that blondel was actually
studying that's later in the 20th
century when people like kojava nip
elite are kind of you know
uh what would you say they're
they're they're making the claim that
this is really the the real stuff you
know the logic is important but not that
many people are reading it
so
um
yeah how would i put i mean i wouldn't
place them in
in relation to hey because other people
have already done that work
um unfortunately most of that has been
done in german and isn't translated uh
peter enrique is is an important person
in that
um mandela is definitely responding to
hegel but he's not like saying that
hegel is the most important person uh in
in studying philosophy by any means i'm
just going to adjust this lighting a
little bit
you know hegel fits into
modern thought which is very much
focused on the subject and
hegel is kind of an interesting
antagonist because
he is interested in religion but
religion as even kierkegaard pointed out
in a very different sense than many
religious people
um
view it now mcintyre mcintyre got to
know blondel in part because i brought
up uh blondel in conversations with
mcintyre that i had at notre dame after
we did the
seminar as well as gabriel marcel
i i said to mcintyre i came in and
mcintyre you know we were doing sort of
a back and forth he wanted to find out
stuff for me specifically about blondel
in part because i talked about these you
know
1930s christian philosophy debates right
at that time i was working on that book
and um so he kind of grilled me on on
blondel who he didn't really know well
at the time
and then i also told him you know have
you ever read gabriel marcel and he said
yeah i mean i've read them a long time
ago and i said your work has a lot of
themes in common when it comes to like
the body
and
how to interpret things with with marcel
and he was like well i'll have to give
check him out you know
um
now
i think you're probably asking because
of the concept of tradition so blondel
does have a a concept of tradition uh
it's not exactly the same thing as
mcintyre's concept of tradition so we
gotta you know be careful to avoid
ambiguities but there is significant
overlap and room for productive
interaction i would say
um so that that's that's i guess
probably enough on that
um
davood good to see you davood i owe you
a long email i'm actually going to say
something
personal here
a friend of mine
and we have been connected though we've
never actually been in the same place at
the same time we've been connected
virtually as is mark smith same same
sort of deal
maybe they will actually meet up face to
face and davood wrote me
do we you know we've done these these
sessions if you haven't seen them on
davood's channel which is by the way
very good
um we do these these things where we get
together
and we just kind of chat for about an
hour about a given topic and the next
one we're gonna do is about humility um
we've done uh ones about like work and
other things
and and my my
the mood loads of the thing in his
channel i was gonna take sort of like
the best hits of them and and i haven't
gotten around to it yet
and i i you know davood wrote me
so it's a while back and i got caught in
a bad dynamic that a lot of you probably
wind up in as well so i didn't respond
to the email right away about what we
should do this this month right
and then you feel like oh man if i write
back i better make it a good email right
so
then you
put it off and it gets down further on
the to-do list and then of course with
being you know worn out i i didn't get
to half of the stuff i was supposed to
do
and it you can keep on adding more and
more like oh now it's really got to be a
good email and the thing to do then as i
did just a few days ago is to email back
and say oh really sorry for being out of
touch um let's
start this conversation
going so that may be a little help for
for some of you
who are procrastinators of such
uh ben feltz to quote the title of
angela's book believe prisons are
obsolete well that's a complicated
question a lot of prisons are obsolete
prisons per se are not because you
better figure out what you're going to
do
with people who are incredibly dangerous
offenders when i taught at indiana state
prison
you know we would get into these
conversations where a lot of the guys
would be like yeah you know i tell the
judges i tell the the volunteers i tell
the chaplain that i'm innocent but
actually i did this stuff and i did a
lot more than they caught me for
but you know i still sentencing
guidelines in indiana are kind of harsh
and you know i think that there should
be parole they didn't have it at the
time in indiana
um but see that guy over there
i hope that guy never gets out of prison
because he stirs the living [ __ ] out of
me what are you gonna do with those
people
now i understand that's that's a smaller
number than the general prison
population
but these these you know abolition
things those of us who've actually
worked in prisons and interacted with
prisoners
i think a lot of us are pretty dubious
about that and so it's kind of a
non-starter
i think a good you know starter is
figuring out how can we drastically
improve prisons
how can we reorient them but should we
get rid of them all together that seems
very naive to me
thomas lodger how different is the
stranger in french well
you got to see what you mean by
different obviously it's in a different
language but it's a language that's you
know much closer to english than say
czech or
yoruba
you know so
it's it's written in a
very simple to read french
and any english translation should
probably reflect that i mean you'd
actually have to ask you know how
different is it from this translation to
this translation to this translation
not something i've really done
um so i i don't think i have a good
answer for that
uh raco wallock asks a question that um
i i don't know if i'm the right person
to answer this do marx's published works
represent a coherent system or do
publications after a certain point
represent a change in his thought i i
mean i don't see a difference between
those to begin with uh i mean are you
saying
that a coherent system would be like
every single work has to be like on
exactly the same page because systems
evolve you know so
particularly
dialectic and dynamic
um i mean marx is in his system if we
want to call it that talking about how
change happens and and changes in
consciousness so like hegel it should
take account of that
um i i don't know that if it's if it's
one big coherent system it's certainly
an incomplete system because a good
portion of it is trying to make sense
out of how capitalism works and
obviously capitalism did not stop
evolving
with the death of marx i mean a lot of
transitions in the 20th century
and the 21st century that might not fit
in all that well i mean marx is pretty
comprehensive in addressing the the
matters of his his time so
but i don't really have much more to say
about that
jeff says um
uh i hope i'm doing well thanks uh what
do you think of henry bergson
any favorite works of his just finish
time and free will and definitely want
to read more yeah that is the place to
start time free will
actually a translation
of the title which is should be
translated as the essay on the immediate
givens of consciousness or the immediate
data of consciousness the essays or the
donation
and that's a good place to start because
you get a lot of the key ideas of
bergstone woven in there the difference
between quantity and quality spatiality
temporality
i mean i think
that
bergson and maurice blondel
are basically doing good phenomenology
outside of the phenomenological movement
and a good friend of mine who is at
boston college he's uh he might be dean
of the library now i mean he's kind of a
go-getter guy
wrote a christian dupont
wrote a dissertation at notre dame
that
very conclusively argues that the the
opening to german phenomenology in
france
that we see happening from like the 20s
through the 50s the way to that was
paved by bergson and by blown down i
would say we should add gabrielle marcel
to that as well
um
but yeah bergson is important um
he uh you know he's got an interesting
book on laughter which clearly doesn't
get to the
sole root of comedy because there isn't
one but it is it is a good contribution
um he's got this interesting work that
he brings out during the christian
philosophy debates but it's not really
related to it the two sources of
morality and religion
um and so there's there's a lot of
untapped potential you could say in
bergson's work
he was important for revitalizing
metaphysics in in 20th century france so
well worth reading
um
benjamin thanks for making great videos
you're welcome do you have thoughts
opinions on ordinary language philosophy
and your neoplatonism yeah they're not
related at all
they're they're not
connected to each other ordinary
language philosophies of 20th century
analytic sub movement and
um
veganism and neoplatonism is something
that goes back you know several
millennia and takes on a number of
different forms
um some of which get
largely incorporated into
christian and
uh thought uh to some degree jewish
thought was you know feel of alexandria
as well so i don't see any connection
between the two of them
um
yeah
uh ephron would you say hegel is the
greatest philosopher to ever live are
there any flaws in his work many many
flaws in his work history didn't end
when he said it ended right
there's
there is no greatest philosopher ever as
far as i'm concerned so that's kind of a
non-starter for me just like there's no
greatest uh
metal band even for me you know i mean
wearing a motorhead t-shirt right
because i love motorhead if you would
ask 16 year old greg who's the best
metal band of all it would have been
iron maiden now if you ask me you know
there's like a constellation of stars
that are all connected together it's the
same way with philosophy you know why
would hagel be the greatest philosopher
ever i think anybody who spends a lot of
time with hegel
and isn't a sort of cult of shigellian
um
is going to see lots of flaws and
is you know take the shine off of him
just as much as if you spend a lot of
time with descartes or plato
these aren't
perfect sages
these philosophers
michael says this is a more of a local
question i'm hearing aaron rodgers may
wind up in tennessee what do you think
go petco
um i don't know i mean i i think so
aaron rodgers for those who don't know
american football right he is one of the
greatest quarterbacks um in terms of
talent in terms of common sense and
you know being a role model
kind of a schlub these days you know he
got himself into a lot of hot water over
his fake vaccination status and then
lying about it and then blaming people
for it and all that but let's put that
aside he's he's you know a top tier
court
and um unlike tom brady he he was never
really surrounded by a
machine to you know
provide him with victories um
what is rogers gonna do well
one of one of three things so one is he
could just retire in which case the
packers are kind of screwed right
because now now we're placed into the
position of trying to find another
really good quarterback because we've
been so spoiled
or really since the 90s right we had
brad farve who was great but super
flawed i mean he threw lots and lots of
interceptions and then we got aaron
rodgers who was on the bench while brett
favre was was there and rogers turned
out to be just amazing like you know
like farv except without the
interceptions
and and a much better leader than far
far as a thoroughly stupid guy
and
has gotten himself involved and scandals
not just about dick pics but about like
you know robbing the welfare system down
in his home state just a you know kind
of a real real schmuck
but a good player right so we've gotten
used to having really really good
quarterbacks and then you know sometimes
good defensive players
good um you know supporting offensive
players
what's gonna happen if if rogers retires
well now we gotta find somebody else to
fill that that spot and we could turn
out to be like some of the other teams
that just never found anybody like the
bears our our big rival
um they keep on looking for the next
great quarterback and it just doesn't
happen for those poor bastards right
um or he could go down somewhere else uh
tennessee the titans
that would be a big surprise um
i don't know why
he would want to be
um there
i mean he's he's a he's a west coast guy
by by birth and training
he's lived in green bay which has this
really like great fan base and stuff
like that
why go to a spot like tennessee
you know i mean there's there's nothing
there really um that would that would be
attractive
other than the chance to like you know
build his own team and i guess you know
the titans did pretty good but
i don't know there's other teams that
people were talking about him going to
um
or he could stay in green and if he
stays in green bay that just kicks the
can down the road if you know this
expression kick the can down the road it
means you you don't solve a problem
right now you solve it later and maybe
he gets to go to the super bowl you know
this coming year you know
although we've had so many shots to get
there and we we just keep screwing it up
um maybe he's tired of that you know uh
we'll we'll see what happens with the
management of of the packers and who
they want to bring in but no matter what
sooner or later we got to get a new
quarterback right so
all right thanks ollie uh
i'll see if you've got any questions
down there somewhere and uh rough bumble
oh
yeah so this is interesting thank you
for your good review of how animals
grieve so i'll say two things about that
um one is barbara king herself actually
thanked me on twitter which was really
nice you know when the the person and
she's not a follower right uh when or
she is now i think but you know when
somebody out of the blue says hey i
liked your your review of my book
um and there's somebody you know who's
got some considerable stature in the
field uh that's that's pretty cool the
other thing is i am working and this is
not something that's going to come out
like this year or next year or anything
like that
i'm working on a book
and this is why i read barbara king
on how to make end of life decisions for
pets
for the owners right because it's very
difficult i saw my wife
having to go through
making decisions that were very tough
for our uh the you know the one cat that
we have
who who died years ago and then we've
had two dogs as well and they're both
gone so i wanted to you know when i saw
the title i was like that's probably
some good research for me and it turned
out it is it is quite good research it's
a great book i'd recommend it
all right um
cinder do you think the theory of
resantamont is used as a way
naturalizing power perhaps i miss red
shaler but near the end he seems to do
that well i don't think there's a theory
of horizontal
i think that that mock shaler uh
reinterprets nietzsche's conception of
resentment can it be used as a way of
naturalizing power i don't think it's a
way of naturalizing power i think it's
certainly a way of trying to
get people interested in your points of
view right it has some relations to
power but i don't see
i don't quite see naturalizing power as
part of that so
and i will say this that resontama is
definitely
a complex phenomena
that um
you know
it's different to nietzsche it's
different in shaler it's different than
other people who
who make use of it so it's it's kind of
hard to talk about a
theory of it um
nonagan what resources would you
recommend for someone wanting to get a
comprehensive view of the history of
philosophy history of philosophy
read around
i don't i don't have resources that i
would suggest for that there's there's
absolutely no substitute for actually
doing
the reading
and i would lower the bar don't try to
have a comprehensive view of the history
of philosophy because guess what nobody
does
nobody that i've ever seen does
even the people who are pretty good like
cobblestone there's people who are left
out so i wouldn't i wouldn't worry about
a comprehensive view
um
alejandro which do you think is better
for intermediate readers confessions or
city of god why not both uh intermediate
readers in what sense too are we talking
about intermediate latin readers
augustine is going to be tough for you
then
intermediate readers of philosophical
works
you know
they're both they're both things that
you should encounter and read um one
thing that you will have to get used to
is there's a lot of scripture references
and you might want to skip over some of
them because augustine will sometimes
just lard them in until you figure out
what he's doing with them right
may to clay
how do you deal with insecurity about
posting philosophy blogs blog articles
i'm guessing if you're new to it i want
to post things i've written but feel
insecure i haven't done enough research
or that it's not good enough well
you can
preface your blog article by saying
maybe i'm not the last authority on this
and i'm sure there's better
people who to talk about this but here's
my here's here's my my view
and that sort of gets your audience
ready
you know you could also consider where
are you going to post it there's there's
some places that are probably a lot less
hostile and a lot more
receptive than others you can write your
blog and you don't have to make it
public right away
there's lots of
lots of ways that you can kind of
cushion
the blows of rejection that i think
you're probably
fearing right um
and you know i will say this too the
only way that you get good at writing
stylistically in terms of a researcher
reflection is by doing lots and lots and
lots of it so
if you want to start a philosophy blog
maybe you keep it private at first and
only share it with a few friends
but you do a lot of writing
and over time your writing is going to
improve
and you can also go back to earlier
stuff that you wrote i do this myself
and say
how can i update this how can i make
this better like i'm taking stuff from
my blog erexis diana tk which i started
way back when i was teaching at
fayetteville state university i want to
say like in 2009 or 2010
and i've been slowly closing that blog
down taking articles that are still
worth reading and putting them into my
medium
space
so you know maybe maybe that would be
something
all right uh
let's see here
and l have you read any gram harmon
little bits i've also met the guy and
interacted with him
not super impressed um
i kind of think the the speculative
realism thing i you know when people
were talking about their have you
learned about speculative realism i was
like
this doesn't really seem that new to me
uh maybe i'm not getting it you know
um so yeah i've been kind of
underwhelmed
you could say
um
russell uh says what do you think of the
work of nick land
not much
it's not crap it's not great um it's
kind of standard fair continental
philosophy from the 80s and 90s
in early 2000s it's you know there's a
lot of assertion
very little
you know
making backing up the claims that he's
making
uh i kind of think he's become one of
those figures that a lot of people like
with hegel too right a lot of people are
like super indicated but they don't
actually understand what hegel is saying
so it's got this kind of pneumonia or
aura of being really cool stuff if you
actually understand what he's saying
which i do because i've heard the people
that he's he's talking about and
referencing you're like yeah okay that's
that's a nice conference paper um
i mean i would disagree with it here
here here i think that this is just wild
speculation
um and you know this is very jargony
uh there's a lot of substitution of
jargon for for like genuine engagement
with things
but that's like you know thousands of
other continental academics of that time
so
yeah
um
ron james have you ever read the
account of monte cristo i haven't read
it it's one of those things that i
probably should have read when i was a
kid
but uh didn't
um
i know are you a fan of early death
metal black metal extreme stuff nope not
interested in that stuff at all um other
people i'm not knocking it other people
might be interested and think it's cool
i'm interested in classic heavy metal
which does include say you know venom
right
um but what black men will turn into is
is a good bit different than what venom
was doing in the early 80s by the way
when venom were describing themselves or
at least cross interviews
it was like we're black metal power
metal speed metal he wasn't saying we're
exclusively black metal a new genre
which we are the you know originators or
anything like that that revision stuff
from later on
um i i just you know i knew kids who
were into death metal when i was in high
school and i was like
i'm not going down that route i'm
interested in in that you know it
doesn't doesn't
grip me
um
so you know
i'm much more interested in
proto metal in this in the late 60s um
actual classic heavy metal in the 70s
and 80s and then what those bands were
doing later on in the 90s through today
and in genres of metal that kind of
spawned from that like you know thrash
i'm interested in that in power metal in
the new wave of traditional heavy metal
of course you know
um and that's you know that's that's
where i uh spend my time you only get 24
hours a day and you can't do everything
so
you know
my my tastes were formed kind of early
um in the in the period when a lot of
this stuff was coming out
then i picked up a book with myerson's
identity in reality or are you familiar
with it not only am i not familiar i've
never heard of it so
uh anal 313 debt what does the bottom or
ground express in nietzsche's rope
walker analogy from the spoke
zarathustra um you know a hard surface
that you die on
i don't i don't know that everything in
a metaphor has to have a correlate in
something uh i mean it'll kill you right
it'll break you
russell
do you think there's an inherent
philosophy to bitcoin i mean if there is
it's probably
a selfish uh full of yourself [ __ ]
right because most of the people that i
i encounter who are all about bitcoin
fit that description uh no i don't think
there's any sort of inherent philosophy
to bitcoin i think that people you know
bring in stuff to try to explain what
they're doing and it's usually some
really half-baked uh uh philosophy stuff
i i mean
it's attractive to libertarians but
libertarians are as a movement
completeness right
so
yeah i don't i don't know that there's
there's any sort of thing to that i mean
we could also ask is there an inherent
philosophy to nfts no i don't i don't
think so
um
audio seems to be stuttering a little i
don't have any control over that so you
know those those sort of comments
totally unhelpful right there's nothing
i could do about it
uh velvet rose i've been reading
aristotle politics watching your videos
about it which translation is the best
one from your perspective i have a video
dr sadler responds which translation is
the best the short answer is i don't
know
but you can watch the video and find out
i am not a uh compare translations and
recommend them because i can read it in
the greek so i don't know
um
ollie power what do you make of giannis
uh
varro fox's position that capitalism has
been replaced by techno feudalism
um i haven't actually read him so i
can't weigh in on that any sort of
everything has changed sort of
narratives i i'm pretty skeptical of
myself
um so i you know techno feudalism sounds
really cool but i don't know exactly
what it amounts to
in uh his theory so i'm i'm leery about
uh saying anything
about that
um cinder have you read dominico le
sordos's book on nietzsche nope i mean
most people asking me questions about
fairly
obscure authors the answer is going to
be nope you know again 24 hours every
day
there's not a lot of time to read
everybody i spend most of my time
reading and rereading primary texts
i'm not i'm not usually very big
on reading secondary lit on on people
these days
and i you know i may be like leaving
myself out of the conversation i'm cool
with that if i can understand nietzsche
on nietzsche's grounds that's great you
know
uh rant man
sovereign citizen oh one of those do you
think the tragedy of the commons relates
to economics and that we're nearing a
fiat collat collapse
i don't think we're nearing a fight
collapse whatever that happens to be
um
you know and the tragedy of the commons
does it relate to economics yeah we talk
about business ethics all the time
um
but
what is the connection between these
things i don't see a connection
all right gerard
i'm new to philosophy i've been reading
some encyclopedia stuff before getting
into works proper
utilitarianism is the only ethical
theory that makes any sense to me but it
seems to be looked down upon by a vast
amount of people who tend to discuss the
topic on forums and whatnot why is this
so so i mean don't give a [ __ ] what
people on forums say
to begin with because
um
a lot of them from my experience of
looking at forums a lot of people don't
know what the hell they're talking about
so why pay any attention to them i mean
go you want to see some crazy stuff go
look at the stoicism facebook forums
they're 90 you know either garbage or
grifters and then you know ten percent
decent stuff but the ten percent decent
stuff gets those same people weighing in
so you don't wanna take what people on
forums is as particularly determinative
um utilitarianism
uh perfectly respectable philosophy as a
matter of fact it gets used a lot in for
example business ethics right
um
the uh you know there's a utilitarian
tradition that you can read which
officially begins with bentham and it
includes mill and siddwick and goes all
the way to peter singer in the present
i wouldn't you know i mean if i were
saying something like this is the only
ethical theory that makes sense to me i
would look at that statement and say
wow given the fact that a lot of smart
people have other ethical theories that
make sense to them maybe there's
something wrong with my current
perspective in that i'm thinking that
this is the only one that makes sense i
mean utilitarianism a lot of it makes
sense to me so there's a lot of virtue
ethics so does a lot of deontology so
does a lot of ethics of care because
they all have
something worthwhile to them hell even
and even ein rand got some things right
usually things that other people got
right as well but
so
um
don't just read encyclopedia stuff
because you don't know whether it's
right or not i mean when you read a
history of philosophy or encyclopedia
entry
how do you know that they got kant right
maybe they didn't
right it's sort of like the translation
problem you don't know whether a
translation is a good translation until
you go to the original and read that
unless you can find somebody else who
you have confidence in who can say well
this is no this is a really good one
how do you know that uh
the encyclopedia stuff that you're
reading doesn't leave out key figures
like say mary wallstonecraft you know
read a lot of history philosophies
very important uh 19th century 18th
century virtue ethicist and and first
wave feminist not even addressed in a
lot of them
good example of a contemporary uh
history philosophy that is should be in
this way grayling's history of
philosophy
very very few women authors
even though they deserve a place in that
history and why uh because i guess
grayling must be kind of uh just
following
um
you know a a
[Music]
misogynistic tradition or something
jonathan can you help me understand the
hopeful
tone at the end of genealogy's second
treaty second essay you mean turning bad
conscience in on itself how is this
possible
um i mean nietzsche thinks that bad
conscience
was able to make interesting you know
sort of like uh the priest figure he
talks about in the first essay and some
of that is spelled out in the third
essay right we realize that we are
halfway healthy halfway sick and we use
the resources that bad conscience
developed for us like the introspection
and asceticism and all that we use it
against itself
is there like a blueprint for that no
there there isn't uh unfortunately
you know you can you can think about
what would nietzsche and do in those
those cases
um
all right let's see here
you know not even a question here just
repeating something that white had said
and probably one of the dumber things
that whitehead has said western
philosophy is just footnotes to plato i
mean
that's ridiculous anybody who's spent
much time studying western philosophy
knows that's that's a nice line but
definitely not true
um
only one i just wanted to thank you for
your help with the myth of sisyphus and
hegel and zarathustra much appreciated
oh you're very very welcome glad that it
was helpful to you
um
uh saladin uh
question i get kind of often love your
work when i ask you work a lot on
christian philosophy have you ever
wanted to go into jewish or islamic
philosophy
um
i've you know i've read some but it's
always in translation and i don't read
arabic so
there's no point in me trying to put
myself out there as uh an expert and
there's many other people that you could
be
why go to me on something i'm not
particularly good at when there's plenty
of other people you can go to we
share the labor so no i'm not i'm not
interested in
doing work on islamic philosophy i don't
read hebrew so there's not a hell of a
lot of point in me trying to um you know
go into much jewish philosophy i mean i
read philo of alexandria because he
writes in greek all right so
uh you know and of course there's the
septuagint stuff like that but
no i i mean and i don't do
you know i so i've got a book here right
this is an important thing but would you
would you really say that the majority
of the work that i do is on christian
philosophy
i'd say maybe
half depending on how we define
christian is descartes christian
philosopher then he he falls into that
that bunch is hegel a christian
philosopher yeah okay maybe uh like
stanley rosen said if he is he's in a
church of one you know because nobody
else uh really holds the the views on
christianity that hegel himself develops
um i mean i do a lot of work on
pre-christian
um
greek and roman philosophy and a lot of
work in
modern philosophy and
late modern philosophy so
um
there are some important christian
philosophers i i do work a lot on like
anselm of canterbury but
um
um another one basically the same answer
ephron have you read any islamic
philosopher uh are you planning to read
any of these personalities what do you
think of islamic philosophy something
for other people to do right it's not
not my area
not something for me to really say
anything about
i'd be more inclined if i was going to
do work on another area to look into you
know the vast history of chinese
philosophy but
all right
raid
do you think there's anything to
nietzsche's views on order of rank among
men or is it silly elitism yeah there's
there's things to think about
nietzsche's views on order of rank among
human beings not just men
um
it's not just silly elitism um
you know there's lots and lots of
philosophers who have views on
order of rank among human beings
um
i'm not sure
i mean are you against elitism just in
general
you've got to define what you mean by
elitism then
all right um
[Music]
let's see here
rt brian johnson says epictetus looks to
natural acquired relations to locate
social roles is this a proper
application
if i take on a husband and wife relation
then i have a role as a husband yeah
epictetus is super clear about this
johnson just happened to write a whole
about it the role of epictetus um which
is i think is a good book um it's got
some some flaws in parts from my point
of view but you know he wrote a book and
i didn't so he's he's a good step ahead
of me on that matter uh epictetus very
much about fulfilling our our roles you
know our obligations one of the good
points i think actually about brian
johnson's book
is that
he doesn't just talk about epictetus he
also talks about the concept of roles in
cicero's on duties which is another
another great work
russell henry bieber what do you think
of curtis yarvin the dark enlightenment
thinkers
i first started reading them when i was
still living
in indiana and teaching in the prison so
we're talking about um
early to mid 2000s i thought they were
they were interesting but very
derivative
um i a lot of and this is in part
because i was working on
um 20th century
uh french philosophy
uh like you know maurice blondel and i
was you know encountering proto-fascist
organizations like accion francaise and
sharomura and reading all this this sort
of you know traditionalist stuff um
traditionalist in the real sense not not
the people who call themselves
traditionalists today who are not
actually traditional about their
traditionalism
um people like you know demise and the
bonald and and laminae and people like
that um
i found what he had to say interesting
in parts but like from a sort of flawed
vision overall and often often you know
as time went on more and more and more
superficial as he became a media figure
i think um he kind of declined to go
back to the nick land stuff the stuff
that land has been doing since he got
into dark enlightenment from what i've
read of it and i can't say that i've
read all of it it's it's kind of
flattened out you know it's it's not
very
insightful or interesting i think so
a lot of people really got into it you
know um
and understandable because it's you know
it's exciting
and all of that
all right uh
ashwin
i had asked this question last time but
earth see book 4 ending so we're talking
about tahanu still bothers me her use of
violence to resolve a conflict is so
unlikely it's not true at all
is there a deeper meaning or something
more attending
violence or justice
is it just like sheer violence a dragon
shows up attacks everybody
no
i mean the
creator of everything
uh the oldest dragon in existence
shows up
to save his daughter and somebody else
who by the way in the last book
he had brought all the way to to rock
and then to gant namely the arc mage get
so i mean the way that you're construing
it places an emphasis on one little
feature
rather than on on the context and i i
would say that's probably where your
issue is arising you know
um i mean if you think that
violence wasn't involved in some sense
in
the previous three novels i i don't
think you've read them adequately you
know um there's dying in the tombstone
right and
one of the key resolutions is uh ara
slash tenor almost kills get right she
gets a knife out and she's gonna stab
him and then she gets control over
herself wizard of earthy
um he assimilates the shadow but he's
fighting the shadow and in um
the the farther shore
they kill cobb
right so who's been killing all these
other people and dragons so i i don't i
don't really see a problem like that um
yeah there is a deeper meaning or
something more to the ending i mean
uh
theroux the burnt child is recognized by
somebody who later on we find out is not
just um cholesky in the oldest dragon in
existence but segoy the very creator of
earthsea
as his daughter
that's pretty damn significant you know
we have an overcoming of evil force
happening so
all right uh greco says have you ever
worked on politics uh yeah
i have articles out there on politics
uh thomas have you ever done
psychedelics like mushroom uh do they
have an effect on you i mean your
worldview or philosophy no i've i no the
strongest thing i ever i've ever done
you know is ecstasy
and i can't tell i mean this was back in
the 90s when i was with a a druggy
german girlfriend and i was i was high
and drunk at the time so i don't know
what sort of effect it really had on me
oh i will say this
i did have a cousin
who um
again back in the 90s
who uh
sprinkled ccp
into the joints that he was passing
around and i did not like that
experience at all um that was that was
pretty pretty rough
i'm not into psychedelics um i myself
consider them
you know
here's my take
they don't open the doors to
consciousness unless there's already
something lacking very lacking in your
life if you need psychedelic and you
can't do aesthetic exercises or you know
meditation to get to the same place
then you want to ask why why you need
the psychedelics you know
um so i'm not you know i'm not a big fan
um
huxley by the way drew a lot of
criticism from spiritual leaders who are
like you're trying to shortcut the
process and like all other shortcuts
you're missing stuff along the way so
i'm not i'm not big on that
craig um
curious if you're aware of any resources
that evaluate or analyze human behavior
current or past behavior
similar similarly as how economists try
to model actions in a financial market
or scientists um
i mean economics is trying to model
human behavior right um yeah there's all
sorts of
models out there i don't i'm not
particularly well versed on them because
i don't do quantitative analysis or
statistical modeling or stuff like that
and i think
anybody who wants to put much faith in
those probably needs to read mcintyre's
after virtue the chapter on the social
sciences
because as soon as people figure out
that you're trying to like metricize
uh them they they start becoming very
unpredictable
and so um you can model whatever you
want i mean a lot of stuff is more
science fiction than actual science
i would i would say you know
all right uh
ssrv
what has been the musical experience
that has most impacted your experience
as a philosopher or researcher or reader
well that's a good one that that is
tough to think about
um
musical experience that has affected
how i read how i philosophize how i
research
um
i don't know that there is a lot of
interconnection between the two of those
um
i mean i can say
recently
we went to
honda's messiah
you know and we and we did so at the
milwaukee symphony orchestra which is
just like four blocks that way
and uh
i'd never actually gone to a performance
of that before it was really interesting
for me
because as somebody who has worked on
you know
christian thought and throughout the
years
you know you see just how much handle
was weaving in from
some of paul's letters
some of the old testament
particularly the psalms you know
um
and uh
you know seeing the people come forward
to sing the solos and and you know
looking at it as a work was really
something different than the typical oh
yeah you know that we always hear right
there's so much more to that work and i
was kind of reminded of like
great works by other people from you
know early the early modern mid-modern
period right like milton's paradise lost
or things like that so
but i don't know i i don't i don't have
a
[Music]
thing that's really impacted my
experience as a philosopher or a reader
rp have you read psycho cybernetic i
don't think so
emergence as a means of perfect as
participation i noticed in your
bookshelf tour you had a copy of philip
k dick's exegesis
if you have any thoughts about that work
or dick's speculative thought in his
later years generally
i think that uh
you know the exegesis is really useful
when i go to do like talks on dick for
seeing what he has to say about his own
writing about this stuff um
you get you get to peer into the mind of
the author himself
um i don't think that it really is an
exegesis in the complete
sense of having a text which then is you
know explored
and it's not just about this you know
mystical experience or anything that was
so profound for him it's about all sorts
of other stuff i mean he weaves in like
you know discussions about robots and
whether they can can have empathy or
things like that so it's kind of it's
kind of a cool work i would i would say
you know
all right
dct revit what do you think of mark
cuban saying that the future of higher
education as it relates to the workplace
will be liberal arts or philosophy well
i think it's very nice of him to say
that that's um
good work if you can get it is he
putting up a you know a ton of money
that he's got to make this happen that's
what i'd be more curious about because
there's lots of people not just mark you
know cuban who said liberal arts matters
or or you know philosophy matters
um
[ __ ] like uh rubio saying you know um
we don't need people studying philosophy
we need people studying welding as if
there's like an infinite amount of
welding jobs available
there's somebody else saying no no the
liberal arts do matter right um and
that's nice
what's g what's the actual like
proposal to make this happen in a time
when you know
liberal arts are really being cut great
example and i'm going to point in
another direction
you know 12 blocks say marquette
university catholic jesuit university
going the same way as a lot of catholic
higher ed they've shrunk the course
several times
now you only have to take one philosophy
class your entire time at marquette and
one theology class and one writing class
right
they're called
foundations of and you can't do much in
a semester right i've taught those
classes not the philosophy ones not
theology or or
rhetoric
if places like that are allowing the
professional schools in marquette's case
business dentistry
law
medicine
you know uh phys physiology and stuff
like that to crowd out the liberal arts
what do you think is happening in other
places
where there isn't a tradition of giving
a [ __ ] about the liberal arts i mean
it's great if cuban wants to talk about
that what's his uh
what's his intervention that's what i
would i would want to know that would be
kind of cool see then then he can become
a hero to people like us
uh francis do you think there are
objective standards for quality and
works of art or regular fiction writing
and such yeah but they're at a lower
level i mean can you spell the words
right that's an objective standard um no
you know maybe in some cases you don't
need to there's always like there's an
exception to the rule but in general you
gotta you know
spell your words right and use
punctuation but that's at a low level
right are there objective standards the
higher up we go then what you mean by
objective do you mean like is there a
checklist is there something everyone
will agree upon
um probably not
you know i don't know that we need them
though
oh here's a good personal question
stephen warren have you ever experienced
unrequited love and is there any advice
philosophical or otherwise that you
found helpful in this regard if you're
asking whether i've felt unrequited love
as the lover then the answer is yes
that has happened in the past
are you asking whether i've ever had
people love me who i don't love back i
don't feel the same way about them the
answer is also yes
and you know do i have any advice about
that advice about
i mean i i think
lurking in the background is the idea
that if you have unrequited love that's
a bad thing
and somebody like kierkegaard would say
oh no that's actually it's a great thing
you can become a knight of infinite
resignation you know you can love your
lover and you don't have to always get
something in return as a matter of fact
if you really do love them then
maybe it shouldn't bother you that
you're enacting something in return
right that's that's one way of looking
at it
or you could also say to yourself
well hell
there's like 7 billion people on earth
if i'm not getting the love i want you
know this sort of temporary feeling that
i've got right now towards this person
and they're not responding in the way
that i want
maybe i can find somebody else
odds are you probably can
and i mean you could also think about i
mean it could be a useful uh exercise to
say well why don't they deserve me back
why don't they love me back and maybe
the answer is stuff that you're not all
that happy about looking at you know in
yourself but you could change you know
um i mean
let's be really silly about this you
know
what if you only take showers once a
week and you know you're a really cool
person
but your personal hygiene leaves
something you don't brush your teeth you
know you don't comb your hair
and then you know you find somebody and
you love them and they're like yeah i'm
not really that into you you know and
you notice they like hold their face
away a little bit well that's an easy
one to fix right start taking showers
start brushing your teeth um there's a
lot of other things that are harder to
fix than that right
uh
let's see here
russell henry barber have you ever
listened to captain beefheart yeah but
it's been a long time since i have
um
oh zach do you have any tips for
engaging in political
philosophical discussion with friends
make sure they are the kind of friends
that want to discuss political and
philosophical things with you
some friends just want to like watch the
game and eat porn and say oh yay and
stuff like that and that's okay you know
you don't have to try to talk philosophy
with them others want to go on hikes
with you others you know want a [ __ ]
about um
politics but don't want to go into
any depth about it because you know
they're happier just griping and getting
to be worked up and they don't want to
have any like you know reflective
self-insight
you have to have the right kind of
friends and then you know the other
thing is
you're probably gonna have disagreements
at certain points and it is important to
remind yourself is it being right that
matters to you or is it
maintaining the relationship not not to
say that you should like buy and drink
somebody else's kool-aid right
but
at a certain point you do want to say
we're gonna
i'm not even gonna say we're gonna agree
agree disagree that's presuming that i
speak for you uh let's just
leave this where it is and we'll talk
about something else and if you've got a
wide range of friendship
you can do that right that's the nice
thing you can find other things to do
together where you don't have to be
talking um
at odds with each other right
uh
nathan
oh good question other than bergstone
and whitehead are there any other good
processed philosophers to look into
there are in fact um heartshorn
hartshorn was a major major process
philosopher
here in the united states he wrote quite
a bit about it charles hartshorn so he
he would be somebody i would i would
check into um
all right um
michael jimenez getting ready to do a
full reading of aristotle's metaphysics
with some friends aside from the physics
is there any other aristotle text
we should read as prep should we bother
with the logic so there is no the logic
there is a bunch of logical works there
is no single book the logic
yeah you probably want to read through
the categories i would say
that couldn't hurt
interestingly you're going to see
things in the metaphysics that reference
politic example you start
uh
causes and principles and he brings up
you know
uh
decisions made by pro-racists made by
people as being causes you know but it
doesn't mean you have to read the
politics
you know reading the physics before the
metaphysics can't hurt
probably you want to read on the soul
you know
that might be helpful as well
there's some good discussions in there
about like taking multiple perspectives
on things so
yeah um
wim
asks what are your thoughts on
nominalism
do you think the abstract exists due to
conscient idealism or that the abstract
is present in the concrete i mean these
are some very abstract terms all
together
i think that there are some things that
nominalism is is right about
you know um they were very keen to like
look at terms and say
quite often we don't have any sense of
what the hell we're talking about you
know let's dig into these things that
the scholastics uh you know are are
you know
rivals at the time yes nominalism arises
within scholasticism but it also
continues outside of that um
you know there are some points on which
they're they're probably right um
i'm not sure why you would have to buy
into some sort of conscient idealism to
get away from nominalism there's all
sorts of ways to get away from
nominalism what's the
original um
sort of framing for
being a non-nominal is being a platonist
and there's all different ways to
understand the the abstract or the ideal
or the
universal right
william what do you think of orthodox
christianity i don't have a think of
orthodox christianity that's too that's
too wide too vague to actually answer
um
gareth uh they asked if you've ever
written about
urgency or top-down causation or talked
about it in your videos
yeah lots of videos but they're not
videos where i'm saying today i'm going
to talk about emergence or today i'm
going to talk about top-down causation
it's you know explicating the text
people themselves who have talked about
that
so you know a great example of this is
the argument from intelligence in
cicero's on the nature of the gods an
argument that kind of fell out of favor
saying you can't get intelligent things
from just you know random processes
there has to be some top-down causation
that has intelligence being the cause of
intelligence so yeah i've talked about
these sort of things a lot but never
just me sitting down and talking about
him it's always me talking about
augustine talking about it or
you know cicero talking about it or
somebody else
all right um
let's see
oh here's a really interesting political
question
ridicule
if you had to guess what do you think
aristotle's assessment of the american
constitution would be like if he were
alive today
so first we got to clarify something
when aristotle talks about a
constitution
he does not mean a written document
he means you could have something like
that he means the entire set of like
top you know level norms
so he would probably include the things
that
constitute the organic law which would
also be like the declaration of
independence but he you know if you look
at you read the book the constitution of
athens
it is a political history from the
beginning all the way up to the present
that for aristotle is the constitution
the underlying structure so you could
say that what the tocqueville is doing
in uh democracy in america is talking
about the american constitution in a
aristotelian way
what would he think of our current state
of affairs and previous states of
affairs he he'd probably agree with the
tocqueville
in the assessment that america has
always been
america as a political entity has always
been a
deeply racist country
and did incredible injustice de
tocqueville talks about this to the
black and red reeses
we could expand this further
um
and that that is a significant problem
when you do things like that and you
don't fix it like through an actual
reconstruction
you're really laying yourself in for a
lot of trouble because you're going to
perpetuate injustice and you're not
going to have a good society
aristotle would say that americans are
you know far too consumeristic
um they
leave you know serving in the military
to
poor and to the thematic um and
spend way too much money on on military
stuff sort of like his criticisms of
sparta you know in the politics um
getting very little yield in response
and that our
policy making is
very schizophrenic you know
i i think he would consider us
essentially a a screwed up state so and
he would say that we're basically an
oligarchy you know
um
let's see
what else we got
ricky have you ever lectured on marcus
aurelius yeah i mean you could google
sat you know gregory sadler marcus
aurelius and i would imagine some of my
lectures marcus aurelius would pop up in
in google um
so i i i i'm not as big on marcus as i
am on epictetus and seneca
um i think they're more important to
read it's unfortunate that like
aurelius is the go-to person for so many
like you know
beginner stoics
um
because i i think you know i think that
that's in part because of the popularity
of
holiday and his constantly talking about
irelias and i think it's also because
aurelius is like kind of all scattered
all over the map and so you can like
just pick and choose things rather than
reading
more systematic treatises by epictetus
and and seneca so
but i think epictetus and seneca really
go much deeper
into things
all right uh i just skipped a little bit
let's see
what do we got here
um
[Laughter]
i find people insulting philosophy a lot
why well
a lot of people are [ __ ] and
ignorant to begin with right so we got
that side over here
a lot of philosophers are [ __ ] and
and you know talk down to people and uh
you know uh you know espouse positions
and then you know look at you with a
blank stare so you know it's easy to
hate people like that
and a lot of people also read things out
of context and you know there's also
philosophers who bash other philosophers
think about like karl popper and his
stupid stupid read on plato um and then
you know you will you read carl well
he's a philosopher right so plato must
be a bad guy right i think of ein rand
you know uh iran is uh
an enemy of plato and a proponent of
aristotle but her aristotle's like
totally you know it's not totally wrong
it's that it's not possible to get
something totally wrong but it's clear
that aristotle right
um so you know i i'd say philosophers
contribute to that and you know the
the uh disdain that a lot of people have
for the humanities in general is
probably part of that so
um
[Music]
let's see here
ridicule do you think some sort of
global governance cosmopolitanism is
necessary to deal with the scale of
today's problems
that's the the thing that sucks probably
yes and it ain't going to happen
so
you know we can't even get our crap
together here in this country the united
states which is like the giant trent you
know going around busting everything up
we can't even get things worked right
you know
so that we can like fight qvid or deal
with climate crisis which clearly was
happening
um
how's the world going to do it
so
it sounds kind of rough to say that
uh russell henry bieber have you ever
have you read gravity's rainbow or do
you plan to haven't and don't plan to
uh i i you know i i'm sure a lot of
people love it but i got better stuff to
do with my time there's so many other
books for me to read you know
uh tobias are you a christian if so are
there some key thinkers that were
decisive for it are there some key
thinkers that are almost worth being
christian for yeah you know i am a
christian and i will say something that
i've said before
i find most interesting
the thinkers for whom being or becoming
christian
did not solve all their problems but
rather made their world more rich and
complicated and spurred them to doing a
lot more work somebody who i've been
shooting videos on this last week
augustine
the confessions because i'm teaching a
medieval philosophy class
that that just started recently at
carthage college
i mean
becoming a christian did not like
shrink his world view it actually
expanded it you know um gabriel marcel
another another convert right a lot of
times he's converts um
chesterton
explicitly frames this in his orthodoxy
um
you know there's almost like a proof
for god's existence there
that is based on like the world becoming
richer by actually entertaining the
hypothesis
kierkegaard blondel you know a lot of
these thinkers uh and some
um somebody i do a lot of work on
you know um
so there's there's tons and tons of
interest in christian thinkers uh
loctancias is somebody i'm a fan of you
know he's got these writings this book
on divine anger which actually tells us
a lot about human anger where he also
considers the positions of the platonus
aristotelians epicureans and stoics
right i like that stuff where it's
really
it's not just some bible thumper saying
dumb [ __ ] because he's read a verse here
or there it's like people who are
engaging the world engaging other people
understanding themselves trying to make
sense out of this this crazy thing that
we call god that doesn't just you know
make everything simple and clear that's
that's the kind of stuff i'm i'm
actually attracted to
all right um
eli says i'm a beginner to philosophy
taking a class on hegel domino's spirit
you poor bastard it's so difficult i
haven't been able to fully comprehend a
single paragraph should i drop the class
and build up my philosophical repertoire
before coming back to hagel yeah
probably so i mean
when you come back to hegel don't start
with the phenomenology of spirits start
with the lectures on the philosophy of
history and the lectures on the history
of philosophy start with a book where he
names names and make a lot easier for
you
um i don't know why anyone would would
tell you to start with the phenomenology
of spirit
that is like
you know you've never driven a car
before and they're going to put you into
a you know a
formula
one race you know or you've never
actually played football before and you
get drafted to the nfl and you're going
to be you know an inside linebacker
that's just not going to work so
yeah i mean hegel's tough um hail is
pretty high up there in difficulty level
um that's what i would say
so
muzzle paint you are the ace of spades
that's very nice uh
oops just skipped a little bit
um
in search of great books what are your
favorite essays budger hmm that's an
interesting question i mean
i
teach
uh to undergraduates as the introduction
heidegger
what is metaphysics i think that's a
great essay i think it's got a lot of
the key themes that heidegger works
through works with throughout his career
in like a little capsule form so that's
that's a good one
um on the essence of truth i think is
really important um
you know
i'm not as big on the later heidegger
stuff except maybe the question
concerning technology
i also like heidegger's lectures on on
things
i think that those are a great resource
for understanding
heidegger's thought and for
understanding what it is that he's
lecturing on so he's got like a great
set of discussions of i mean he's got
like four four volume lectures on
nietzsche which i think are quite good
um he's got discussions of like plato's
cave and you know aristotle on
affectivity and you know phenomenology
of the religious life there's all sorts
of really cool stuff
and it's all been
i don't know it's all been most of it's
been translated recently so that's
pretty cool
um
here we go diogenes do you think
heidegger was right to consider the
political or art as techne being the
correct way to figure out the essence of
technology or it's saving power i think
he's right
to consider it and a way i mean there's
multiple ways to understand
technology um
max thanks for your work reading plato's
parmenides for metaphysics class
do you have some things about the
content i should keep in mind as i'm
reading yeah i mean there's basically
two parts to plato's permanentes right
there's the the easily readable hey
parmenides old guy hey socrates young
guy how's that uh you know view of the
forums coming along to you hey xeno what
are you up to they they go back and
forth and chit chat that's that's cool
stuff right there
and then we got this crazy
dialectic
thing uh and it's i've never really
fully understood what the hell's
supposed to be going on in the rest of
the permanentes myself it's for me it's
always been something you just kind of
work your way through and hope that you
get something out of it so i don't have
a lot to to contribute about that
unfortunately
um
let's try to take a few that we haven't
uh answered already from other people
um
let's see who i haven't
had before
um
this is a great one from adam hegemon
i started reading nature and it's making
me wish i hadn't because it seems
correct and i hate him for it how do i
know his thoughts with that of the
philosophers and the antiquity you don't
you you read your way through it now
just you know work on one thing at a
time
and
you know
so what if you find yourself attracted
to it you're are you finished with your
philosophical development are you going
to like go out and start you know
preaching nietzsche on the street
because of this probably not
so you know there's not a ton riding on
this
um and which philosophers of antiquity
nietzsche is pretty receptive to
aristotle for example and pretty
hostile to plato
or to the stoics right so it's not just
the philosophers of antiquity
there's there's actually
you know a rather complex field
i wouldn't worry about it too much
this is this is kind of what happens
when you study philosophy and you do so
for the first time with a particular
figure you start to see the world their
way
do it long enough and some doubts will
creep in
and um
you know you'll start to engage in
critique of them and say well wait a
second nietzsche
where are you getting this from you know
um
[Music]
let's see
uh ashmar is the gutting of philosophy
in the liberal arts overall due to a
general public devaluation of things
that don't generate capital has america
become far less introspective both
what's going on neither it's
this is a trend that's been going on for
a very long time it's just it just so
happens that the universities work kind
of you know
imperfect
oasis from from that and they've been
i mean you could say that it's part of
the capitalist process you know uh
universities have in effect become uh
gutted and colonized by
um all these concerns and by having
boards of trustees who are
people and stuff like that and hiring
hiring managers essentially for for
administrators rather than having people
rise up from
from the uh ranks of the professorate um
but this is not something radically new
there
people have been talking about the
waning of the academy the entire 20th
century and 21st right so
it it doesn't have just one cause either
uh hooky says i'm currently reading
shopping hour for a module at uni and
your con series really helped me
understand the critique any advice and
understanding schopenhauer yeah i i do
have a few things any anytime that he
mentions hegel just ignore that he's a
sour puss and he's off base when it
comes to hegel and he's got some you
know psychological uh
what would you call a thorn in his side
that's that's making him say stupid
things
um
schopenhauer's taking kant really really
seriously and he's also taking plato
seriously and he's trying to bring
all these other things together he's
also taking the philosophy of sympathy
quite seriously as you can see in his
works
so it doesn't hurt to not just read kant
but also bone up on plato and you know
some of these other figures as well
um
i mean the same thing can happen to you
like
uh
who is it that was just talking about
nietzsche
uh
where you reach open hour and eventually
you like almost take on his point of
view
that's okay
you'll probably come out of it
um but if you don't you'll be in good
company because there's many of other
people who have done that
uh
ed to dawwin our dream experience is a
metaphysical issue so is there any
literature on the matter there is a vast
literature going back to antiquity about
dreams
um
and you could probably just google it
and find all sorts of sources can it be
a metaphysical issue yeah what's going
on in dreams
what's happening are these images in
some respect real or are they just you
know
fantasmata you know images that we we
produce what what do dreams actually
mean these are all sorts of metaphysical
issues i'd say
um
maxwell what do you think of protest
protestantism as a catholic i don't i
don't think as a catholic and i don't
think of protestantism because that
name's at this point in time over 10 000
different denominations
that's the sort of like big picture
everything is everything thinking that i
don't really do
so
and i would i would discourage others
from doing that as well
we're getting close to the time when i'm
gonna have to go get some lunch um but
let's see what else we we have
um
what are your thoughts on newer writers
posting or publishing their works on
websites like wattpad or whatnot great
yeah i mean
uh post stuff wherever you want to um
you might run into some jerks
um and
you know i i look at a few things on
wattpad over the years um i i don't know
how you find
quality stuff in it it seems like it's
just like a big tub of things right but
yeah it can't hurt right i suppose you
might have to worry about
people plagiarizing you that could be a
concern so
um
[Music]
let's see
ephron have you read any mysticism what
do you think of mysticism and do you
believe in god yeah i've read plenty of
mystics um i think that you know there's
like real mysticism and then there's
[ __ ] new agey feel-good mysticism
and they're two very different things i
think somebody claims to be a mystic the
first thing i'm gonna ask them is okay
what do you actually mean by that and if
all they can do is kind of circle around
the top like with like oh man like you
know the stuff that i i feel and i have
this you know unique insight i'm like
get the [ __ ] out of here your bloodshed
yeah i i don't ever want to waste any
more time with you if it's somebody
who's like hey um i've got these
insights and i'm trying to communicate
them i'm doing the best i can and i'm
not dismissing anybody else and trying
to place myself above other people
okay that that's more interesting to me
um
all right uh
julius you're always looking for
practical insights from the people you
read
what practical insights have you taken
away from and or implemented from
heidegger
um
i think he's right that you know in his
discussion of the four equi-primordials
i think that's actually brilliant from
being in time
that mood affectivity
does
um
pre-understanding is articulated through
language does flow from our our
throneness and stuff like that i think
that's that's actually quite brilliant
um
you know there are varieties of what he
calls negative behavior i think he's
right about that too you know so those
are some
right there and you know the need to
like
slow down
pay attention see what's actually being
unconcealed don't expect everything to
be unconcealed at once i think that's
that's good advice too
um
let's see
ass dance dance dance
something something do you feel chinese
philosophers bring different concepts to
western ones or are there many overlaps
in that aspect
um the dot like the dao of lao tzu
drungzer magnus
there's lots of overlaps and there
should be because we're all rational
beings growing up in different systems
and then sometimes later on when there's
connections actual connections between
western and chinese philosophy from the
time really of the jesuits being there
exerting some influence
these culture spheres are connected with
each other
there should be lots and lots of
overlaps
and
[Music]
you know
we should avoid easy identifications
confucius isn't aristotle right even
though they they both have a mean right
um
but you know there's there's
interconnections and we'd be silly to
think that like
east is so different from west no i mean
both of them have similar things going
on and that's just chinese and and what
we call western philosophy indian
philosophy entirely different cultural
sphere right not it's not that there's
eastern philosophy that's chinese lumped
into the same thing as indian as islamic
which is a you know in a in a middle
area as well so
all right
let's see if i can take one more we're
already over a little bit over time
[Music]
frederick walzer are we really rational
beings yes
and you're engaging in rationality and
even raising the question and expecting
an answer are we pure purely rational
beings are we completely rational beings
no rationality involves a process of
purifying that very rationality that we
often deal with right
but
that is part of our nature and are we
the only rational beings
maybe not maybe um some of the higher
animals participate in rationality in
ways that previous philosophers didn't
want to acknowledge you know we've got
like human beings on one side and then
all the other animals on the other maybe
the cetaceans and uh you know octopi and
you know corvids and elephants and
higher apes and stuff like that
maybe they participate in rationality
you know that's that's something to
think about but yeah we are we are
rational being so that's that's a
fitting place to end
i'll say thanks to everybody for their
questions ideas comments uh good ama
once again
i gotta go and get some some food in my
belly before i meet with my uh patreon
supporters for philosophy chat
and then start uh
this afternoon i got a full slate of
shooting
videos on the confessions
scheduled for my medieval class which
you will eventually see as they
they come out as i release them right
now i'm in the process of finishing up
with my last earth-sea books and
events like this so all right i'll see
all of you somewhere else in the ether